morning John let's talk about friends
the physical insides of any given person
and roughly to say we got do you know
the skull and the backbone and the ribs
the other hand underneath the emotional
skin then we create and show to the
world we are all very different
we are differently broken
semi-functional rusted-out love machines
and i don't mean love machine i mean
like we are just good at you know aside
from eating and making babies we're also
really good at creating important
relationships with each other the
process of becoming friends with someone
this is what friendship is to me is
physically removing all of that
constructed emotional putty that we make
ourselves pretty to the world with and
uncovering all those rusted edges
beneath and then actually continuing to
like that person not just in spite of
all of that asymmetry but because of it
and that's simply not something you can
do with very many people like that takes
a lot of work and it's a it's like a lot
of upkeep too but that's why when people
study the number of friends that people
have they're not looking at the number
of Facebook friends you have they're
looking at the number of people that you
could share really intimate things about
your brokenness with and on average it's
not very many it's between two and three
people per person you last video John I
will take exception to some of the
things you said I would not vote all the
difference between that emotional
intimacy of friendship and the emotional
and physical intimacy of romantic
relationships that's a big difference
but I do agree that friendships in our
culture are undervalued and romantic
relationships are I just almost said
romanticized our culture spends a huge
amount of time celebrating and
glorifying romantic relationships the
process of getting to romantic partners
together has become an industry and
people take in-depth compatibility
quizzes to make sure that they find the
right romantic partner and we don't do
those sorts of things for friends just
too bad in some cases because when you
don't have good friends it can be really
hard to find them I don't know about
that so yeah - the title of the video
this took a long time but how do you
make friends psychologists in the 50s
figured out the thing that is necessary
which is repeated unplanned interactions
and that's a hard thing to fit and it's
also why a lot of things we have are
from school or work where those
unplanned interactions take place so if
you don't have those two things which a
lot of us don't these days because we
don't work in a physical place good
friends you got to put yourself in a
place where those on play
the directions are gonna happen I won't
give you a list of how to do that you
should use mind and figure it out it's
not that hard then you also have to take
advantage of those interactions when you
have them so don't forget about that how
to take the initiative sometimes you got
to start conversations you have to share
yourself you have to start working away
some of that emotional putty from
yourself don't think of each interaction
it's like a means to an end but an end
and itself help people yes but even more
important let them help you don't be
afraid to ask someone for a favor
because that's how friendships are
started and like top of the list be
thoughtful and listen to people and
think about them complexly which is yeah
that's sort of how you create
acquaintances Facebook friends but to
get to the real friend bits you have to
start having important conversations and
so you have to start asking some not
super comfortable questions like what do
you want to be in five years what do you
not like about yourself what do you like
most in the world what do you hate most
about the world those are the questions
that let you pull out all that stuff and
reveal the raw intimidating bizarre
amazing sculpture within and it's hard
to do non organically and so we should
all be very thankful for the organic
video that we do have especially if they
make us comfortable and like us for who
we are and if they don't it's okay to
break up with friends just like it's
okay to break up with romantic partners
and last as a thought that I just had if
you have a romantic partner and they
don't appreciate the bizarre broken
sculpture within or you don't appreciate
theirs that's okay
but don't get married to that person
because it's probably not gonna work out
if you're not friends you have to be
very good friends and John you and I are
both very lucky to be married to our
best friends and I'll see you on Tuesday